السودان
لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله العلي العظيم
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم طائرات الجيش السوداني
تقصف مواقع في الخرطوم ومضادات دعم السريع
تتصدى لها تزامنا مع اطلاق نار قرب القصر
الرئاسي الجيش وقال ان الاوضاع تسير وفقا
لما وضعه من خطط في وقت توالد فيه عمليات
اجلاء الرعايه ودبلوماسيين الاجانب من
الخرطوم
تزامنا مع تزايد وتيره النزوح هربا من
القتال الامم المتحده تحذر من امتداد
النزاع الى كامل المنطقه وعدد الضحايا
المدنيين يرتفعوا الى نحو 300 قتيل واكثر
من 1500 جريح في حين ناشدت منظمه الصحه
العالميه الداعمين الدوليين توفير مليار
وسبعمائه مليون دولار للسودان الاحتلال
يعتقل 18 فلسطينيه خلال حمله دهم في الضفه
الغربيه الاعتقالات تركزت نابلس والخليل
وجنين واريحا حيث دهمت قوات الاحتلال
منازل فلسطينيين وفتشتها واجرت تحقيقا
ميدانيا قبل ان تندلع مواجهات مع الشبان
الفلسطينيين خفر السواحل التونسي ينقذوا
93 لاجئا من افريقيا جنوب الصحراء بعد غرق
قواربهم في عرض البحر كما تحدث الحرس
الوطني عن عثوره على 30 جثه متعفنه قباله
سواحل البلاد واحباط ثلاث عمليات هجره غير
نظاميه خلال الساعات الماضيه الى اللقاء